LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow,
what a great keynote.
In this keynote, we saw about
how technology was being used
to solve the world's problems.
I'm Laurence Moroney.
I'm reporting from the
Coffee with a Googler stage,
here on level 2 of the Moscone.
And some of the
technologies that we
saw in play during the keynote
were things such as the Android
M developer preview.
I'm looking forward
to downloading it
and trying it out for myself.
We also saw updates to
things, such as Android Wear,
and some fabulous stuff that's
available in the Internet
of Things space, such as Project
Brillo and Project Weave.
I particularly enjoyed
the Photos app,
and some of the
things that we saw
that are available in the
Photos app, and the fact
that we can store all
of our photos and videos
online for free.
But I think the
crown and glory of it
was the stuff that's happening
in the virtual reality space.
There was the new Project
Cardboard was announced.
And I see people walking around
with the new Cardboard devices
now.
And including that,
there was also
the Project Jump, which
will allow you to film
your own virtual
reality 3D videos.
Just incredible stuff.
And speaking of videos, we've
got this great new series
that's coming on the
YouTube Developers channel.
It's called Made with Android.
Let's take a look at that now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Go, little balloon.
Go.
You can do it.
Hey, great launch.
VIMAL BHALODIA: How far
away are we from the--
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: 52 miles.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Oh, wow.
It's still going strong.
It's still pinging
regularly with locations,
and that's fine.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
My good friend Vimal
is great at coming
up with crazy ideas,
and I love helping
him implement them.
And he told me about
his crazy, awesome idea
to send cameras up
on weather balloons.
And I was all in.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
I'm Heather Brundage.
I'm an engineer,
an explorer, and I
like to go on crazy adventures.
VIMAL BHALODIA:
I'm Vimal Bhalodia.
I'm a serial entrepreneur,
software engineer,
and maker of random things.
ALL: We're the Casa
de Balloon Club.
And this is Made with Android.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Launching
weather balloons
is kind of an interesting
engineering challenge,
plus the fact that you can
get pictures of the earth
from 80,000 feet,
where you actually
see the complete
blackness of the sky
and the curvature of the earth.
And it's absolutely incredible.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
We used Android
because it was a very
affordable device.
Another reason why
we used Android is it
had fantastic documentation.
VIMAL BHALODIA: One of the
greatest things about Android
was that it was very
easy to pick up.
Literally just
downloaded the SDK,
read through the first tutorial
on how to build an app,
and then built the
first prototype of this
all in an afternoon.
Instead of using
this battery, were
going to be wiring in
one of these holders.
Up above 30,000 to 40,000 feet,
the normal lithium batteries
that are sitting in
your phones will not
work all the way up there
because they'll just freeze.
We actually have to
hook our phones up
to external battery
packs that are
using disposable, lithium
primary batteries.
I actually do all this
in my living room.
I just have a little bench.
And you don't really need that
much to do a project like this.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Our
most basic payload
is just an Android phone.
And with that phone, we're able
to get GPS location, as well
as altitude.
Android allowed
us to take control
of the phone in a low
level way that we needed.
We're using these
phones in a way
that they're not designed for.
And other phones
don't let you do that.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So the app that
we developed for our balloon
launches is pretty much the
polar opposite of a normal,
well behaved mobile app.
A normal, well
behaved mobile app
tries to be very careful
about power consumption.
It tries to play well with
all the other apps that
are running.
It doesn't want
to hog resources.
We want it to be
running all the time.
We never want it to sleep.
We want it to always be the most
important app that is running,
and make sure that,
if for whatever reason
the phone reboots
because of a low power
situation or something, our
app comes up and running.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
That's something
that a lot of other phones don't
allow you to have access to.
But Android allowed us
to have that control.
VIMAL BHALODIA: And there's
our phone booting up.
Good times.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Checked the
weather for this Saturday,
and it actually looks fantastic.
Ahead of time, I end up doing
a lot of work on the computer.
And I'm looking at
wind simulations
to figure out a good
launch location,
as well as expected
drop zones, checking
that against no-fly zones,
and airports and big cities
to make sure that we
don't have any issues.
And, oh.
It'll pop over Los
Banos and land--
VIMAL BHALODIA: A
little bit over--
BOTH: [INAUDIBLE].
VIMAL BHALODIA:
That's not a bad area.
Nice.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Sweet.
So it looks like Saturday's
going to be good.
We do run extra predictions
right at the time of launch
since wind predictions are only
so good, and they can change.
VIMAL BHALODIA: I'm going to
be preparing the payloads,
putting in the batteries,
turning on the phones,
just doing a final
check to make sure all
the software's running.
It looks like it's working.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: We've also
added in an Android camera.
So it's not a phone.
It's specifically a camera.
So it's much better
than the camera in just
a regular Android phone.
VIMAL BHALODIA: There are
a lot of different things
to worry about in
these payloads.
We have a bunch of
trade offs with respect
to weight, power
consumption, the electronics
and their sophistication.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Are you guys ready?
VIMAL BHALODIA: At
the day of the launch,
we have a minimum
of three people.
We have the helium person,
the balloon person,
and the lift person.
And then ideally, we also have
a fourth person with us who's
reading off the directions.
FEMALE SPEAKER:
Slide balloon neck
approximately 3 inches over
the PVC balloon fill nozzle.
VIMAL BHALODIA: This is
by far the hardest part.
FEMALE SPEAKER: All
right, helium filled?
VIMAL BHALODIA: Ready.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Go.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Ooh,
this is perfect.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Great.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Yay.
VIMAL BHALODIA: All right.
Then we tie the
payloads to them,
let them go, cross our fingers.
ALL: Three, two, one.
Wooh.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Go, little balloon.
Go.
You can do it.
Wow, that's really
awesome to see.
Oh, man.
Look at that.
It just "woosh."
Yes.
Once the balloon is in the air,
we're actively tracking it.
We have two devices in there.
They're both sending
us GPS location.
So they're close.
They're a little
off from each other.
But you can see she's
drifting south east ever so
slightly, which is
exactly what we expected.
We do lose contact with the
balloon at about 20,000 feet
when it leaves cell reception.
The cell phone is still
getting GPS data up
to about 60,000 feet when
it then loses GPS data.
When the balloon
rises, it expands.
And when it gets high
enough, it bursts.
And that's when the
parachute deploys
and it starts to
descend back to earth.
At this point, it's
falling at about 5 meters
per second with the parachute.
And it's spinning around.
So it takes it a while to get
a cell reception and a GPS lock
once it gets below there.
It could land on a
freeway, which we hope not.
It could land in a farm field,
or it could land in the water.
We don't know.
VIMAL BHALODIA: The worst
part possible thing that
could go wrong is that
the payload actually
lands on a road or
inside a crowded area.
And we take a lot of precautions
in choosing both our launch
site, as well as our
expected landing site,
to make sure that that's
not going to happen.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: We could just
lose the balloon completely,
have no contact with
it, the batteries
could die, the phone
could stop working,
the program could
crash and not reboot.
And if we don't hear from it,
we're not going to get it back.
VIMAL BHALODIA: About
half the launches
that people have done
and blogged about,
they never saw again.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Hey,
to a great launch.
MALE SPEAKER: Hooray.
ALL: Cheers.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
To a full recovery.
VIMAL BHALODIA: To
a full recovery.
Oh, wow.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: She
went pretty far south.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So
it's in a field.
We don't have to worry.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Right in a farm field.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Perfect.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
Let's go pick it up.
This was a perfect day
for Central Valley wind.
It was exactly as
we usually expected.
A nice southeast wind.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So I'm about as
zoomed in as I can possibly be.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
And here, wait.
Let me show you the map.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So one of
the great things about using
an Android phone is actually,
in addition to using GPS,
we're also using
network triangulation.
So we have a much more
accurate location spot on it,
down to a couple of feet.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Just hoping
there aren't, like, snakes.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Or sprinklers.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Or sprinklers.
Typically, we can see the
red parachute sticking up.
This time, we couldn't.
So we have this big, green
field and no red dot.
So we had to start
tromping through the field.
But finally, we got right on
top of it, and there it was.
Found it!
ALL: Woo!
Awesome!
HEATHER BRUNDAGE:
The Android device
knew where it was
well enough, and was
able to communicate its location
to us well enough, that it
led us right to it.
It was a homing beacon,
effectively, just purely
through GPS data.
And even if all we knew was,
hey, it's in this field,
it would've taken us forever.
A combine would have
found it before we did.
We would have had to fly
over the field to see that.
Oh wow.
Oh my goodness.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Everything is
still pretty safe, and solid,
and secure.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Oh, man.
Look at this.
It pretty much--
MALE SPEAKER: It tied
itself into a little Pompom.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Wow.
VIMAL BHALODIA: So here is
our happy, reliable phone.
It's been ticking along.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Still on?
VIMAL BHALODIA: It is still on.
It has a great connection, too.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Awesome.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Everything
looks to be in tact.
When we recover the payloads,
we bring computers with us,
and we like to look
at the picture.
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: Which
is really satisfying,
at the end of a long day,
to see these pictures
that you've just retrieved.
If other people are interested
in doing ballooning,
our code is open source
and available online.
VIMAL BHALODIA: Everyone who
does this has their own site,
and has their own blog,
and tells their own story
about their launches, and their
payload, and their experience.
And we've read a ton of them,
and learned a lot from that.
And we also want to share our
story at casadeballoon.club
HEATHER BRUNDAGE: We're
Casa de Balloon Club.
VIMAL BHALODIA: And this
was Made with android.
The problem with regular
lithium batteries
is, when it gets really,
really, cold, they stop working.
So that's why we had to switch
to lithium primary batteries.
Take it away from me.
We're done.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Well,
that was a fun video.
And I hope you enjoyed it.
And I'm sitting here
now with the director
of the video, Brian Grady.
So Brian, welcome to
Coffee with a Googler.
BRIAN GRADY: Thanks
for having me.
You really loved the show.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
Thank you.
So for those of you
guys who are watching,
Brian and I came up with the
concept of Coffee with a Google
together.
He's actually the
brains behind the show.
He's also the beauty
behind the show, as well.
BRIAN GRADY: Thank you, so much.
I never thought I'd actually
be the Googler that you
were having coffee with.
So this a nice of
change of pace.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
my privilege, actually.
So tell us about the
Made With Android.
That looked like a
whole ball of fun.
BRIAN GRADY: Man, we're so
excited about this new series.
It's a web series.
It's a documentary style, as
anybody who saw it could see.
And the reason we're
excited about it
is because we do
Coffee with a Googler,
it's always talking with
Googlers about Google stuff.
And you know, we
don't try to be pushy,
but we want to expose and make
things easier for people to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
BRIAN GRADY: Made With Android
is about finding people outside
of Google, doing things
that nobody expected
them to do with a phone.
So we found out that
there's a lot of people--
there's a community out there.
People that, because of the
extensibility of the Android
operating system, are able to
make incredible applications
that do crazy things, like--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Like
flying a weather balloon.
BRIAN GRADY: Flying
a weather balloon,
or opening your
apartment door when
you're at the top of
the stairs and your bags
are full of groceries.
I don't know how you do that.
Your hands are full
of-- but anyway.
There's things like that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: The
things that people
will think of that we
cant think of, right?
BRIAN GRADY: So we're looking
for stories like that.
We've got a couple lined up.
This is the first full
piece that we've completed.
And we're looking for new ideas.
So if somebody's got any ideas,
if they know of fantastic
things that are
made with Android,
we'd like to hear about them in
our G+ comments on the YouTube
channel.
Speaking of the
channel, we should
talk about the Google
Developers YouTube
channel, which is where the
bulk of my teams work ends up.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
What's the criteria
that you're looking for
somebody to pitch something
for these videos?
BRIAN GRADY: Thanks.
For Made With
Android, we're looking
for non-Google employees.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Rules me out.
BRIAN GRADY: Yes.
We want non-commercial
applications
that are about fun, or
hobby lifestyle kind
of stuff, new connecting
new things that people
hadn't connected.
We want it to be an
open source project.
And we want to be able to,
not only entertain people
and inspire people
with the video,
but also provide them with
the code, the applications,
and maybe they'll go out and
do something else with it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
somebody can pick this
and run with it for themselves.
Like I could actually
go and get a weather
balloon myself, now, and start
doing what these folks do.
BRIAN GRADY: You go
to casadeballoon.club,
which is this group's website.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I love the .club.
BRIAN GRADY: I like
the casadeballon.
But anyway, they have a
whole thing set up there.
You can go there.
You can download their app.
You can see where they've flown.
They have flight logs.
It's really interesting.
It's like sending up,
really, your own space,
exploratory project.
You get these
beautiful photographs
of the earth, which are
in the video, as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I always
wanted to do the slice of pizza
in space kind of pictures.
In this case, we'll do a Coffee
With a Googler mug in space.
I guess, the more exotic
the locale, the better?
BRIAN GRADY: Absolutely.
We're looking for things
to produce-- right now,
I'm looking for things
in the Mediterranean.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm
more a Tahiti guy myself.
BRIAN GRADY: Well,
I hear they're
doing interesting things
with Maps down in Tahiti.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Got to get on that.
BRIAN GRADY: Yeah.
I think we ought
to get down there.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
This show is going
to go on the YouTube
Developers channell, right?
There's lots of great types
of shows on that channel.
Could you tell us about them?
BRIAN GRADY: So we have a team
of multiple producers, at least
four full time producers.
It's really like a television
production company.
And we're putting out, I'd
say, three, four, maybe five
different kinds of content.
We've got very specific task
oriented, instructional sort
of work, where you
learn to implement
an API in your application.
We've got this more
inspirational stuff
where you see what
people have done,
and we don't really dive
into how did they do that,
but there's always a link
to how they did that.
And then, we have a
great LazyWeb shows
for developers who
don't have the time
to sift through
everything that comes out
on the web every week.
We have a rundown of that.
We're going to be doing a
weekly Android round up.
In the next couple
of months, we're
going to start that-- probably
in the next couple of weeks,
I should say.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I'm personally
a big fan of the DevBytes
because, as a developer, there's
so much new information coming
thick and fast every day.
The nice thing
about a DevByte is
I can sit down for three or
four minutes, watch the DevByte,
and then learn if I really care
about that technology or not,
instead of investing a few
hours dissecting a sample
or reading through
documentation.
I watch the DevByte
for three minutes
and I go, yes, I care
about this or, no,
I don't care about this.
It's a great time saver.
BRIAN GRADY: And
that's that the format
that we try to set them up,
that you know in the first 20
seconds whether
this applies to you.
We'll suggest other videos as
YouTube does of similar things
so you don't have to sit through
that one if you don't want to.
But if it's something
that you're looking for.
it's very powerful.
And we're also trying to
make those more entertaining.
We're adding little
intros and outros.
Famous ones are for
Google Play Services
that your partner Magnus is in.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRIAN GRADY: So go look
those up on the channel.
Subscribe to the
channel, please.
You must subscribe.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Subscribe
to the channel, right now.
It's definitely going
to be worth your click.
My favorite [INAUDIBLE] ones
is like when my head comes out
of the coffee cup
and looks around,
and I look really creepy.
You did that?
BRIAN GRADY: I didn't do it.
It was-- maybe, you'll
come out of this?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
BRIAN GRADY: Watch
Coffee with a Googler.
You'll see people popping
out of coffee cups.
They'll eat when
you least expect it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And now,
in addition to all the stuff,
we also have these
Udacity courses, right?
BRIAN GRADY: Oh, yeah.
Udacity is this
great partnership
that's been brewing.
It's really been
working really well.
And we just sort of started
stepping that up a bit.
I think you might
actually-- you're
asking me questions-- you
might know a little bit more
about that program than I do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I know
a little bit about that.
BRIAN GRADY: So Lawrence has--
LAURENCE MORONEY: I was
teeing it up for them.
BRIAN GRADY: Laurence has been
making a wonderful contribution
to the Udacity courses.
LAURENCE MORONEY: We have a
course on Google Play Services
that's launching imminently.
And so in that one, we're
going to be covering
some of the great
technologies that we actually
saw on the keynote, somethings
such as maps, and location,
and ads, said Analytics.
There's so many that
we're putting in,
I can't remember them all.
But one of the nice things
about how these Udacity courses
work is that, if you're
not familiar with them
is that, a lot of the
times, video instruction
tends to be a talking head.
And it's a person presenting,
and then pointing at some code,
and then asking you to
download something, and maybe
read a document.
And then it's just them
continually talking.
It's very one way.
But the way these
courses have been set up
is that they're much
more interactive.
And obviously, you can't
interact with an instructor
because they're on
the computer screen.
But it's lots of short segments.
And then those segments usually
end with a quiz or a challenge.
BRIAN GRADY: And don't you do
occasional live streams where
you'll have the
experts available?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
BRIAN GRADY: So
there is a little.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So there
is that level of interaction.
If you're doing the
nanodegree, for example,
you can interact
with instructors.
And there's also these Code
Jams that they do where
lots of people get together.
I was actually in
Dublin a few months ago
for the launch of one of
the study groups there,
one of the Code Jams around the
Android Fundamentals Udacity
course.
And it was really
cool because that's
when you get a
bunch of developers
together to start working
through all the problems
together because these
courses aren't just
handing you the information
and expecting you to know it.
They're actually challenging
you to do stuff step by step.
BRIAN GRADY: And when a
bunch of people like that
get together in a room, I
mean just as a filmmaker,
to film that and capture some
of what's happening is amazing.
So I want to do more of that.
But you mentioned the
nanodegree program with Udacity.
Wow.
What an opportunity for
people that aren't necessarily
coders to learn how to code in
Android, make an application,
and it's all available online.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
all available online.
And you end up with
a certification
that you can use on your resume.
BRIAN GRADY: This is
getting you a job, actually.
You can actually get the
nanodegree, and get a job.
But we have also made some
interstitial programming
to show for Udacity.
This might be a
surprise for you,
but I believe my friend in
the control room has a video,
it's the Udacity nanodegree--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Let's run it.
BRIAN GRADY: --trailer.
Shall we?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Should we run it now?
BRIAN GRADY: Yes.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Sounds good to me.
KATHERINE KUAN:
The reason why I'm
an Android developer is
because of the platform's
massive reach.
Building for Android means that
you can build something here
and it will reach people all
the way across the world.
In fact, the next billion
people coming online
will interact with the internet
for the very first time using
only a mobile device.
There's so many people who
are consumers of technology,
but I think it's so
much more powerful
to be a creator of technology.
Everyone has unique
experiences and strengths,
and they can draw
on that and use
that to identify problems
in their community,
and then, use technology
to solve that.
I really feel like
there's a big opportunity
to show people that
they can create
something really amazing.
You can imagine something
that you think should exist.
And you can actually
go and build it.
I can't think of anything
more powerful than that.
You can start your journey
to become an Android
developer, today, with Udacity
and Google's nanodegree.